la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport transformé laissé
de l'innovation un impératif pour
réindustrialiser la France demande de la
mission d'information excellence de la
recherche innovation pénurie de champion
industriels chercher l'erreur française
alors je vous rappelle que dans ce débat
le gouvernement aura la faculté s'il le
juge nécessaire de prendre la parole
immédiatement après chaque orateur pour
une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposera alors à son tour du
droit de répartie pour une minute
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez donc
si vous le souhaitez répondre après
chaque orateur une fois que celui-ci
aura retrouvé une place dans l'hémicycle
et la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur de la mission d'information
qui a demandé ce débat madame Vanina
Paoli Gajan rapporteur de la mission
d'information chers collègues vous avez
la parole
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
depuis mars 2020 la crise sanitaire
suivie de la guerre en Ukraine ont mis
en relief les fragilités de notre
économie
ainsi l'incapacité de la France patrie
de pasteur a développé un vaccin contre
la covid-19 nous a brutalement rappelé
que nous ne faisions plus partie des
états leaders dans l'innovation
sommes-nous pour autant condamnés à
jouer le rôle de fournisseurs
d'innovation technologiques de qualité
et bon marché transformés par des
entreprises étrangères en innovation
industrielle qui nous reviennent sous
forme d'importation néfastes notre
balance commerciale
ce n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons la
crise énergétique pourrait aggraver
évidemment ce phénomène puisqu'elle rend
plus difficile la réimpatriation de nos
chaînes de production pour sortir de cet
impasse notre groupe les indépendants à
lancer une mission d'information sur le
sujet dont les conclusions ont été
adoptées je le rappelle à l'unanimité le
8 juin dernier excellence de la
recherche innovation pénurie de nouveaux
champions industriels chercher l'erreur
française cette formulation retenue
était volontairement provocatrice mais
parmi les 125 personnes que nous avons
auditionnées rares ont été celles qui
l'ont jugé impertinentes car je crois
que nous comprenons tous chacun avec sa
sensibilité politique le drame
industriel qui s'est joué dans d'autres
pays
j'en profite pour remercier très
sincèrement tous les membres de la
mission qui m'ont accompagné au cours de
ce travail qui l'ont enrichi de leur
expérience propre et des exemples
issus de leur territoire et
singulièrement son président Christian
Redon sarrazzi qui a su nous faire
profiter de sa connaissance de ces
sujets notamment pour ce qui est de la
formation dans les territoires
nous avons tout d'abord constaté un
paradoxe et en France on adore les
paradoxes d'autres pays investit
massivement en faveur de l'innovation
pour des performances industrielles qui
ne sont pas vraiment à la hauteur
pourtant il n'y a pas de fatum nous
disposons d'atouts nécessaires pour être
une économie de rupture technologique
créatrice d'emploi dans nos territoires
il s'agit donc de tenir compte de ces
erreurs françaises qui ont jusqu'à
présent empêché de transformer mieux
l'essai de l'innovation industrielle il
s'agit aussi de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour que nous redevenions
une nation industrielle innovante et
souveraine
deux principes ont guidé l'élaboration
de nos recommandations d'abord
l'efficacité de la dépense publique le
caractère opérationnel des mesures
proposées
le soutien de la croissance et du
développement des industries innovantes
et l'affaire de tous et seul une action
coordonnée du Parlement du gouvernement
et des acteurs privés pourra permettre
de relever les défis que notre pays doit
relever
le Parlement a un rôle essentiel à jouer
deux tiers des dépenses de soutien à
l'innovation sont des incitations
fiscales notamment avec le crédit
d'impôt recherche qui représente une
dépense annuelle je vous le rappelle de
6,6 milliards d'euros or
son efficacité est inversement
proportionnel à la taille des
entreprises bénéficiaires véritable
incitation à l'innovation pour les PME
il est trop souvent pour certains grands
groupes une forme d'aubaine fiscale
c'est en tout cas ce que nous montre
factuellement une étude de 2019 de la
Commission nationale d'évaluation des
politiques publiques
en effet un euro de crédit d'impôt
recherche versé au PME en traite 1,40 de
dépenses de R&D alors que le même euro
versé un grand groupe ne provoque que 40
centimes de dépenses en R&D
or le crédit d'impôt recherche est très
majoritairement accaparé par les grandes
entreprises puisque 10 bénéficiaires 10%
pardon des bénéficiaires les plus
importants en perçoivent 77% du montant
total
pire encore les 100 plus gros
bénéficiaires captent 33% du volume du
crédit d'impôt recherche
au moment de l'adoption du rapport
l'ensemble des membres de la mission
d'information et ce quel que soit leur
bord politique je le précise ont retenu
que cette situation de rente n'était
plus vraiment tenable
titre personnel je pense qu'après le
quoi qu'il en coûte et le combien ça
coûte notre impératif est d'opté pour le
mieux qu'il en coûte
c'est pourquoi nous proposons soit en
remettre en cause la stabilité fiscale
du dispositif du crédit d'impôt
recherche sans alourdir la dépense
fiscale liée Audi crédit d'un projet de
renforcer simplement son efficacité par
plusieurs ajustements très à la marge
monsieur le ministre nous souhaitons
d'abord supprimer le taux de 5%
au-delà du plafond de 100 millions
d'euros de recherches de dépenses de R&D
pardon tout en augmentant à du
concurrence le taux en deçà de ce
plafond alors d'après les calculs de
l'économiste Xavier jarravel que nous
avons entendu
cette mesure entraînerait une économie
de 750 millions d'euros ce qui
permettrait de financer une augmentation
du taux tout en ciblant plus les
dépenses de recherche des ETI des PME et
PMI de nos territoires
et dire que sans cette mesure nos grands
groupes délocaliseront leurs activités
de recherche ou que nous n'attirons plus
les investisseurs étrangers me paraît
être un petit peu un chantage à l'emploi
contre lequel je m'assure en fait
sinon ça veut dire que ces grands
groupes et ses investisseurs viennent
chez nous pour de très mauvaises raisons
or je pense qu'ils ont de très bonnes
raisons de venir les grandes entreprises
gardent leur centre de R&D en France
parce qu'elles bénéficie d'un crédit
d'impôt recherche de 30% jusqu'à 100
millions d'euros
et non d'un taux réduit au-delà c'est
aussi parce qu'elle s'inscrivent dans
des écosystèmes performants de recherche
et d'innovation c'est aussi parce
qu'elle bénéficie d'une recherche
publique de très bonne qualité et
faut-il s'en réjouir très bon marché
c'est aussi parce qu'elles peuvent
s'appuyer sur des infrastructures de
bonne qualité et sur un vivier
d'ingénieurs et de techniciens qui sont
très bien formés
ensuite nous envisageons de calculer le
plafond du crédit d'impôt recherche au
niveau de la holding de tête pour les
groupes qui pratiquent l'intégration
fiscale nombre d'entreprises consolides
leurs résultats pour déterminer leur
bénéfice global en compensant les pertes
de certaines filiales avec les résultats
positifs des autres en vue de diminuer
leur impôt sur les sociétés or même dans
cette hypothèse le crédit d'impôt
recherche lui peut rester calculé au
niveau de chaque filiale
selon nous les quittés fiscales exige
qu'en cas d'intégration fiscale ce
crédit d'impôt soit également calculé au
niveau de la holding et non au sein de
chaque filiale selon les calculs du
Comité Richelieu une telle réforme
pourrait engendrer une économie de plus
de 500 millions d'euros par an qui
pourraient profiter là encore au PME PMI
innovantes
le crédit d'impôt recherche ne constitue
pas à nos yeux l'alpha et l'oméga de
notre politique de soutien à
l'innovation on s'en fout force de
constater que depuis que nous avons
publié nos recommandations c'est bien
les ajustements à la marge que je viens
de détailler et que nous proposons au
nom de l'efficacité de la dépense
publique qu'il focalise la tension alors
même que nous approuvons la
sanctuarisation du crédit d'impôt
recherche
c'est pourquoi il m'a paru important de
concentrer mon propos sur ce sujet pour
lever tout malentendu le président de la
mission aura tout loisir en conclusion
de ce débat de revenir sur les autres
mesures que nous proposons et qui sont
nombreuses je tiens toutefois évoqué
dans le temps qui me reste quelques
pistes d'action qui ne relèvent pas du
Parlement mais qui sont à la main du
gouvernement un principe d'abord
préférez le chiffre d'affaires à la
subvention mobiliser la commande
publique au service des entreprises
industrielles innovantes et ensuite une
règle d'or faciliter les démarches
administratives raccourcir les délais
c'est avant tout une question de volonté
politique l'exemple du terminal
métallier flottant au Havre dont la
construction devrait commencer six mois
à peine après que ce projet a été
envisagé nous montre qu'on peut le faire
nous devons aligner le temps
administratif et le temps économique
enfin les acteurs privés doivent eux
aussi s'impliquer
pour soutenir le développement des
entreprises industrielles innovantes
chers collègues en conclusion je partage
avec vous un espoir la crise actuelle
constitue une opportunité pour
réindustrialiser nos territoires et
optimiser l'efficacité des dépenses
publiques je vous remercie merci Madame
la rapporteur monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
merci merci madame la Présidente je suis
très heureux d'être de retour au Sénat
je vais bientôt demander mon rond de
serviette ici parce que j'y étais hier
soir pour le rapport sur la souveraineté
ce matin pour répondre à un certain
nombre de questions orales et cet
après-midi avec grand plaisir pour pour
commenter échanger avec vous sur ce
rapport extrêmement important madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président Redon
sarrazzi madame l'un rapporteur Paoli
gagin d'abord merci merci pour le
travail exceptionnel que vous avez que
vous avez accompli parce qu'il est
extrêmement complet on partage avec vous
le constat qu'on a du mal aujourd'hui
encore relier je dirais la paillasse à
l'entrepôt et à s'assurer que la
recherche qui existe en France et qui
est de qualité internationale prix Nobel
de physique le montre encore il y a
maintenant 48 heures a du mal à se
retrouver de manière très concrète au
sein de l'entreprise et au sein des
processus productifs vous avez fait une
analyse systématique de l'ensemble du
processus qui je pense est extrêmement
utile et va nous permettre de réfléchir
à la manière de rendre tous ces
processus plus efficaces je vous trouve
cette une guerre un peu sévère
évidemment sur la position de la France
il y a maintenant quelques jours la
France a été citée classée 12e dans ce
qu'on appelle le Global innovation index
donc 12e pays le plus innovant au monde
c'était en 2022 la France était 19e en
2019 donc je pense qu'on est déjà un peu
en train de progresser j'ai la faiblesse
de penser que le gouvernement précédent
la majorité à laquelle j'appartenais
déjà il y a contribué la french tech
l'accélération du développement des
start-up industrielles je pense il y a
contribué
mais vous avez raison si les soutiens en
faveur de l'innovation vers et dans
l'industrie mathémative les freins sont
encore nombreux ils nous appartient de
l'élever nous convergeons sur un grand
nombre de vos propositions avant d'ores
et déjà mises en oeuvre des actions dans
ce sens j'aurai l'occasion si vous
autorisez madame la Présidente d'y
revenir dans le cadre de ma conclusion
je n'ai pas puisque vous avez un rapport
extrêmement global prévu de répondre à
chacune des interventions mais plutôt de
faire une réponse globale j'espère que
les sénateurs qui du coup seront privés
de l'endroit de réplique nommant
porteront pas rigueur sachez quand même
que sur le crédit importe recherche on
aura quelques divergences mais je les
exprimais lors de ma conclusion je suis
sûr que le président m'en remettra une
au passage pour m'expliquer combien j'ai
tort merci à tous et à toutes en tout
cas je suis très heureux de pouvoir
assister à ce débat et y répondre dans
la à l'issue merci merci
monsieur le ministre
donc nous allons dans la suite du débat
donner la parole pour commencer à Madame
Patricia Schillinger pour le groupe RDPI
si vous le souhaitez même sinon j'ai
bien sûr vous pouvez venir à la tribu
merci Madame
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je tenais
comme pour beaucoup d'entre vous à
remercier les rapporteurs pour le
travail rigoureux exhaustif et expertisé
de ce rapport il pointe les lacunes de
notre industrie et propose des pistes
devant permettre à la France de
redevenir une nation industrielle
innovante et souveraine notre pays subit
en quelque sorte les conséquences de la
croyance à l'oeuvre dans les années
80-90 selon laquelle il serait possible
de décloisonner les activités de
production de sel de conception et
d'innovation de créer en quelque sorte
une entreprise sans usine suivant cette
croyance l'industrie française a été
délocalisée une grande partie de ses
moyens de production détruisant dans le
même temps des millions d'emplois
industriels sur plusieurs décennies ce
sont ainsi près de 3 millions d'emplois
qui ont été détruits entre 75 et 2014
l'inefficacité de se décloisonnement
tendance énergétique et conserver la
maîtrise de ces décisions et ainsi
construire la souveraineté européenne
enfin l'urgence climatique est là l'été
2022 a vu se multiplier les catastrophes
liés au réchauffement climatique ne
dépendances énergies fossiles doit être
derrière nous pour atteindre 40 %
d'électricité ici d'énergie renouvelable
à l'horizon 2030 nous devons diversifier
notre mix énergétique
biométhane biomasse hydrogène des
kabores des carbonées et aux liens en
mer photovoltaïsme exploitation des
énergies des courants de marée un énorme
potentiel technologique et industriel
s'offrent en nous la crise sanitaire le
conflit ukrainien l'urgence climatique
agissent comme des accélérateurs
accélérateurs d'innovation ces défis
nous poussent à faire preuve de courage
d'audace et d'inventivité nous devons
nous donner l'ambition de construire nos
rêves c'est l'objectif de la France 2030
une ambition publique pour répondre les
défis écologique démographique
économique industriels et sociaux dans
un monde de perpétuel évolution ce sont
ainsi 34 milliards d'euros investis pour
qu'en France les entreprises les
universités les organismes de recherche
réussissent pleinement leur transition
dans les filières stratégiques en amont
nous devons mettre les bouts les
bouchées doubles dans la formation et
l'apprentissage sur des nouvelles
filières nos écoles nous organismes de
recherche dans des segments de pointe
au milieu du processus c'est mettre à
une start-up qui débute des recherches
de pouvoir monter rapidement ces
prototypes au bout de la chaîne il y a
la réindustrialisation de nos
territoires elle a commencé et elle va
se renforcer je ne citerai qu'un exemple
celui de St microélectronique à croque à
Crolles c'est à mon sens le symbole de
la réindustrialisation est possible
quand la volonté politique est là ce
n'est pas moins de 6 milliards d'euros
qui ont été investis sur ce site où la
France va créer la plus grande unité de
production semi-conducteur en Europe et
créé plus de 1000 emplois
supplémentaires cet exemple est le
symbole de la France du savoir de la
recherche et de notre reconquête
industriel notre groupe RDPI se tiendra
aux côtés du gouvernement et de toutes
et tous qui veulent que la France
soutenue par nos alliés européens
puissent retrouver sa pleine
souveraineté économique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole
la parole est à madame Gisèle Jourda
mes chers collègues je tiens à mon tour
à saluer le travail de qualité de cette
mission d'information dont la technicité
et la précision n'ont jamais fait défaut
madame me la rapportrice monsieur le
Président votre motivation au cours de
ces travaux n'a eu des gars que votre
connaissance parfaite du milieu de la
recherche merci à tous deux
car comme Obélix vous m'avez fait tomber
et plongé dans la marmite moi l'homme
bleu membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées et surtout de la
commission des affaires européennes je
me suis ouvert à un monde que je sentais
pertinent et au carrefour de mes
préoccupations dans mes différentes
commissions
le système français doit
considérablement améliorer l'innovation
et en faire une de ses priorités les
propositions de notre mission
d'information vont dans ce sens et
gagner à être entendu par les pouvoirs
publics mais le problème ne se limite
pas à la France la dimension européenne
ne doit pas être oubliée l'Europe doit
même reprendre le leadership sur
l'innovation de rupture
face aux avances technologiques prises
ou en passe d’être prise par des
puissances émergentes telles la Chine
comment faire de l'Europe une puissance
qui résiste
prenons l'exemple de la 5G la
législation française est adaptée au
contexte mais il convient de rester
attentif à l'évolution des risques sur
l'ensemble du territoire européen tous
les pays n'ont pas le même niveau
d'expertise sur ces questions il
convient donc de soutenir la mise en
œuvre de la boîte à outils de l'Union
européenne susceptible de faciliter la
mise en oeuvre de mesure nationale dans
le domaine de la 5G et de veiller à
l'évolution des risques de soutenir la
réalisation du projet Xa X et tout autre
initiatives et financement
communautaires susceptibles de favoriser
l'émergence d'acteurs européen de
premier plan dans le domaine de la 6G
soutenir mes commandes
dimension financière et bien non ce
n'est pas qu'une question d'argent il
s'agit de bien définir les thématiques
sur lesquelles on peut créer un facteur
de compétitivité car c'est ce facteur de
compétitivité qui permettra aux géants
d'émerger de soutenir les bons acteurs
en évitant aussi possible les grands
équipementsiers non européennes la
capacité de la France et de l'Europe a
soutenir l'émergence d'acteurs européens
alternatifs et certainement l'une des
conditions silicanes pour garantir notre
souveraineté
dans le spatial l'Union européenne doit
se donner les moyens de rester un acteur
majeur
front de la guerre froide entre les
États-Unis et l'ours l'espace et l'un
des enjeux de la course pour la place de
première puissance mondiale entre
Washington et Pékin la Chine est devenue
une puissance spatiale majeure qui mène
de front des programmes d'exploration
lunaire et martienne des voies habitées
des lancements de satellites à vocation
scientifiques commerciales ou militaires
et même la construction d'une station
spatiale chinoise et nous pendant ce
temps-là cet exemple du spatial est
l'illustration de quatre axes
d'attention que nous devons mettre en
oeuvre faire preuve de la plus grande
prudence en matière de transfert de
technologie 2 définir une politique
nationale et une politique communautaire
qui prennent en compte les récents
développement des ambitions des
ambitions chinoises 3 augmenter les
budgets publics nationaux des États
membres je poursuis mon exemple en
matière spatiale en évoquant
l'importance de donner toute sa
dimension aux nouveaux projets de
constellation européenne pour la
connectivité mais plus largement il nous
faut réaffirmer la nécessité d'une
recherche publique plus forte qui ne
peut s'accommoder d'un enseignement
supérieur en berne comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et depuis si longtemps 4
l'Union européenne doit encourager le
développement d'un secteur privé
performant en mettant en place les
conditions optimales à la croissance des
startups innovantes c'est l'application
cumulative de ces quatre grands axes qui
permettra de favoriser l'innovation et
la compétitivité le rapport de notre
mission d'information vana ce sens la
plupart de ces préconisations est une
déclinisation de ces quatre axes faire
de la commande publique un levier
essentiel de croissance pour les
entreprises industrielles innovantes
c'est l'axe 2 faire de la propriété
industrielle et de la normalisation des
sources de compétitivité c'est l'axe 1
inciter les grands groupes à s'impliquer
dans l'émergence et la croissance des
entreprises innovantes c'est l'axe 4
élaborer des 2022
une loi purie annuelle de programmation
de l'innovation pour renforcer
l'efficacité de la politique de
valorisation c'est l'axe 3 j'en viens
maintenant à un point extrêmement
important qui a été mis en exergue nous
devons préconiser de systèmes
automatiser les évaluations exposent des
politiques de transfert et de
valorisation menées par les organismes
publics de recherche et les
établissements d'enseignements
supérieurs et de confier cette nouvelle
mission au Conseil d'évaluation de la
recherche de l'enseignement supérieur
oui les évaluation doit être une
priorité majeure de nos politiques
publiques elle est en même temps un
enjeu essentiel et une culture que nous
ne possédons pas et c'est bien dommage
sans évaluation l'attribution des
financements sera naturellement fléchés
vers les acteurs déjà installés ce qui
favorisera les consortium qui
bénéficient déjà d'un soutien européen
mais qui ne sont pas encouragés à se
dépasser et à devenir les meilleurs
car les financements viendront quand
même vers eux les industriels eux-mêmes
le reconnaissent nous devons faire
l'inverse de ce que l'on fait
aujourd'hui je cite monsieur Lozère cruc
Pietri
on sécurise pour que le résultat en 2025
soit ce que l'on voulait en 2022 mais le
monde aura changé trois fois entre temps
et on risque de tomber à côté et si le
rapport indique que nous devons
réorienter les aides fiscales pour mieux
accompagner le passage à l'échelle des
petites et moyennes entreprises
innovantes
ce que je te soutiens très fortement je
tiens toutefois à préciser qu'il nous
faut commencer par évaluer du crédit
impôt recherche pour qu'un terme soit
mis aux stratégies d'évasion et
d'optimisation fiscale si souvent
dénoncé et pour endiguer son
détournement par des bénéficiaires
insuffisamment contrôlée
enfin pour aller au bout de l'évaluation
interrogeons-nous sur le rôle que nous
devons donner au Parlement dans les
transformations que nous préconisons de
mettre en oeuvre ne nous oublions pas le
Parlement à toute sa place sur le modèle
de la DARPA l'agence du Département de
la Défense des États-Unis chargés de la
recherche et développement des nouvelles
technologies qui rapportent au Sénat
américain
nous devons également jouer un rôle
important dans ces transformations aussi
bien que dans le SI suivi des crédits
budgétaires que dans le suivi de cette
loi de programmation de l'innovation que
nous appelons de nouveau
je n'ai pas balayé tous les champs de
notre rapport mais je souhaitais surtout
mettre en valeur le fait que c'est un
carrefour et que nous nous devons de
garder notre souveraineté dans le
domaine de la recherche pointue il y a
eu beaucoup de rapports mais celui qui a
été porté par notre rapport iris et
notre président ça a été d'aller plus
loin pour conforter ceux qui ont
l'ambition de faire que l'innovation de
projet soit vraiment au rendez-vous des
ambitions que porte notre beau pays déjà
nationalement et sur le plan européen
j'insiste parce que c'est une valeur à
ne pas galvauder merci de m'avoir écouté
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Marie Noël linman chers
collègues vous avez la parole pour 5
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame Lara bourserie monsieur
le président
je souhaite au préalable
comme vous le savez j'ai des soucis de
voix
je souhaite au préalable remercier notre
collègue rapportrice et le président de
notre mission qui tous deux ont fait un
bon travail et on réalisait un excellent
rapport dont mon groupe approuve la
plupart des conclusions merci à nos
collègues qui ont initié cette démarche
et nous permettent ainsi de débattre et
je l'espère devrait un sursaut bien
nécessaire de la politique d'innovation
de notre pays
car monsieur le ministre j'espère que le
gouvernement va se saisir de ce rapport
et mettre en oeuvre ses préconisations
dans l'enjeu est majeur et que des
décisions urgentes s'imposent
ce rapport complet celui examiné hier
soir sur la souveraineté économique et
l'indispensable
industrialisation oui relancer
l'innovation est essentielle pour la
souveraineté de la France pour la
capacité de notre pays à maîtriser son
destin et son avenir
vous aurez bien noté monsieur le
ministre que le rapport parle de
l'innovation service de la
réindustrialisation et si j'ai bien noté
votre satisfaction devant l'amélioration
du classement français dans l'innovation
générale on pourra toutefois noter que
par exemple sur la french tech
l'essentiel des startups sont dans le
secteur des services et il n'y a pas à
son plaindre mais que la partie
consacrée à l'industrie est extrêmement
faible d'où l'importance de nos
préconisations avec cette cible
particulière
oui force est de constater que d'énormes
retards ont été accumulées et
qu'inverser les tendances négatives qui
ont prévalu depuis 30 ans exigent un
véritable sursaut collectif une
mobilisation générale et des
interventions publiques bien supérieures
à ce qu'ils sont actuellement mais aussi
et Madame la rapporterez vous l'avez
vous y avez insisté des interventions
publiques mieux orientées
développer l'innovation suppose un
terreau fertile or ce terreau est
terriblement appauvri ce terreau c'est
une appétence à la science à haut niveau
c'est à haut niveau scientifique à
technique de nos concitoyens et de notre
jeunesse et là comment ne pas s'alarmée
par la rapide détérioration
je suis persuadé
qu'au-delà des effets négatifs sur notre
compétitivité économique et industrielle
cela concourt à cette spirale dépressive
qui mine notre pays et notre projet
républicain cela mériterait en soi un
long débat mais aussi je ne retiendrai
que quelques sujets majeurs directement
dans le rapport le niveau en
mathématique des jeunes Français a
chuter un point que nous sommes
désormais dans les classements
internationaux dans les derniers pays le
dernier pays d'Europe et l'avant dernier
dans l'OCDE derrière le Chili la ferme
n'est pas nouvelle le rapport Villani
torosian le disait mais les dispositions
prises en 2018 ne suffisent pas
à redresser là-bas
sans compter que la réforme engagée par
le désastreux monsieur Blanquer
aboutissait à ce qu'à peine plus de 58%
des élèves de terminale avaient encore
des cours de maths
et seulement 14 % étaient en maths
expert c'est à dire la filière
scientifique
un désastre si une heure trente a été
ajoutée cette année nous n'avons aucune
visibilité pour l'avenir il faut un plan
complet rapidement opérationnel pour
retrouver à haut niveau de formation
mathématique dès le primaire jusqu'à
l'université cette urgence ici
plus largement la situation de
l'enseignement supérieur est alarmante
j'approuve la demande faite d'une loi de
programmation privée annuelle à
condition mais je sais que c'était pas
l'attention ni d'une président ni des
rapporteurs que ce ne soit pas une tarte
aux fruits comme les sels sur le par le
président gouvernement sur la recherche
lors du débat qui a eu lieu lors de
l'examen de cette loi dans notre
hémicycle nous étions assez unanime pour
dire que les montants étaient
insuffisants et ne permettrait pas
d'atteindre les 3% de PIB pour la
recherche et de 1% pour la recherche
publique nous sommes actuellement tout
juste dans la moyenne européenne bien
derrière l'Allemagne oh c'est un point
majeur pour la compétitivité de la
France sans doute bien plus oppertant
que l'obsédante
l'obsédant de course à la baisse du coût
du travail au passage ce qui défendent
la valeur travail peut l'embêter le coup
ça m'échappe le rapport relatif à la
maison neuve de cette loi par notre
collègue darkos et pieds-noir montrent
que l'État ne respecte pas
ne la respecte pas et notamment la
trajectoire d'emploi et nettement
insuffisante puisque seul 365 16 emplois
ont été créés contre les 700 prévues
sans chercheur comment innover
il faut assister sur la situation
inacceptable des doctorants la phase
vient de publier une étude qui montre
qu'un quart des doctorants ne parvient
pas à subvenir à ses moyens cette
situation explique en partie la perte de
10 000 doctorants en France en disant
comment tolérer aujourd'hui le
doctorants notamment qui enseigne soit
payé en dessous du SMIC j'ai plaidé au
sein de la commission pour que l'on
demande une révision de cette loi de
programmation je voudrais juste pour
terminer madame la Présidente dire
qu'au-delà du terreau à revivifier il
est essentiel de mettre en oeuvre des
propositions et vous aurez le groupe
CRCA à vos côtés madame la rapportrice
pour revoir nous nous souhaitons
radicalement le séisme le crédit pour
recherche mais nous voterons les
propositions que vous écrivez dans votre
rapport
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Pierre
Moga ch chers collègues vous avez 8
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
mission d'information madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues si vous
me le permettez dans un propos linéaire
je souhaiterais adresser toutes mes
félicitations à l'un aspect prix Nobel
de physique depuis mardi nouvelle dont
je me réjouis particulièrement car il
est natif de mon département et je
rajoute je rajouterais même que nous
avons le même âge à quelques jours
d'intérêt nous avons que quelques jours
de différentes
et dans
un propos liminaire dont je tenais à
vous dire ça je remercie tout d'abord
notre rapport triste et notre président
pour l'exceller un travail qu'ils ont
réalisé le sujet dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui est fondamental car de
l'innovation car c'est de l'innovation
que découlent les nouvelles sources de
croissance de notre économie de bonne
santé de nos entreprises la vitalité de
nos territoires ainsi que le progrès
humain face au caractère inéluctable
changement climatique il nous est imposé
de changer le mode de production afin de
restreindre leurs effets néfastes sur la
ville heureusement et atteindre les
objectifs back carbone à horizon 2050
dans une politique visionnaire nos
prédécesseurs nous ont légué le fruit
estimable d'une innovation tout à fait
remarquable une production électrique
quasiment des carbonée nous plaçant de
fait parmi les nations les plus avancées
dans le monde en la matière la crise
sanitaire agit comme un puissant
révélateur de notre manque de capacité
d'innovation notre pays a connu une
saignée industrielle extrêmement
douceuse à partir des années 80 dont
nous payons aujourd'hui toujours les
conséquences en termes d'emplois de
cohésion territoriale et de prospérité
la nécessaire réindustrialisation de
notre pays l'adaptation au climat ne
peuvent passer que par un effort
puissant en faveur de la recherche et de
l'innovation depuis le début des années
2000 la France a su accroître le volume
de son soutien public à l'innovation qui
est passé de 3,5 à
8,8,7 milliards d'euros par an en 15 ans
au total 110 milliards d'euros ont été
mobilisés
de 2010 à 2030 l'écosystème de soutien à
l'innovation a été réaménagé à de
nombreuses reprises créations du crédit
d'impôt recherche
lancement du premier pays des trois
autres la création de PPI de PPI France
en 2012 etc aujourd'hui
la France compte désormais 20 000
startups 27 licornes une seule est une
startup industrielle l'innovation
bénéficie donc en majeure partie au
secteur du numérique la mission
d'information à laquelle j'ai eu la
chance avec vous de participer propose
plusieurs voies d'action qui je le crois
permettront à l'innovation et la
recherche de redevenir le centre de
gravité de notre économie
notre vision de l'innovation est trop
linéaire elle conduit les pouvoirs
publics à la soutenir essentiellement au
travers d'Apple apogée qui ne permettent
pas de construire des feuilles de route
industrielles et technologiques d'avoir
une vision à long terme
avant toute mesure parmi électrique et
sectorielle il conviennent de
solutionner la pauvrerie la
problématique que représente
l'enseignement scientifique dans notre
pays les besoins de l'économie française
en termes de nouveaux ingénieurs sont
estimés de 50000 à 60000 chaque année
nos écoles n'en forment que 33000 par an
ce différentiel contribue donc à un
affaissement de notre compétitivité pour
rester une grande puissance innovante et
industrielle il faut dès maintenant
s'attaquer à la question de
l'enseignement des sciences dans notre
pays si l'on en croit les statistiques
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale le
niveau des élèves de 4e en 2019 en maths
et l'équivalent de celui de ceux qui
avaient les élèves en cinquième en 1995
il nous faut inverser la tendance une
hausse des rémunérations des enseignants
et des chercheurs ainsi qu'une loi de
programmation dans supérieure sont
indispensables pour relever le niveau de
l'enseignement susciter des vocations du
seigneur de doctorat de scientifiques
attirer et conserver nos talents
le lien entre l'innovation et
l'industrie fondamentale 70% de la
recherche privée en France et réalisé
par l'industrie manufacturière il est
donc essentiel d'orienter l'innovation
vers la réindustrialisation en
favorisant les partenariats entre centre
de recherche publique et privé en
permettant à un nombre accru
d'entreprises notamment les petites de
se saisir des dispositifs de soutien
existants il convient également
d'organiser des transferts de
technologie vers des entreprises
françaises produisant sur le sol
national dans cet esprit d'encouragement
de l'innovation il est impossible de ne
pas évoquer le crédit d'impôt recherche
je ne serai pas très long sur le sujet
madame la rapporteur vous l'avez
longuement évoqué et je partage tout à
fait ce que vous avez dit à ce sujet
l'impôt sur les sociétés ayant été je
m'en félicite abaisser substantiellement
durant les dernières années la situation
actuelle offre l'opportunité de
recalibrage du du cire vers des
bénéficiaires en ayant le plus besoin
j'insiste sur la proposition de la
mission qui propose de doubler le
plafond du crédit d'impôt innovation
pour le porter à 800000 euros et
destituer un coupon recherche innovation
à destination des PME car les PME le
constate sur nos territoires la constaté
avec la mission alors vraiment besoin il
nous faut également lever certaines
contraintes administratives que nous
nous sommes imposés amenés après amener
rendant la vie de nos entreprises de
plus en plus difficiles il est temps
normal que laboratoire de thérapie
génique secteur innovant par excellence
en Suisse puisse démarrer son activité
dès le dépôt d'autorisation et qu'en
France il fasse il faille un an et des
fois et des fois plus vous l'aurez
compris nos collègues c'est tout le pays
il nous faut remettre en état de marche
à commencer par notre jeunesse pour lui
donner le goût de la découverte de
l'expérience de l'expérimentation
scientifique il nous faut accompagner
les entreprises innovantes
financièrement mais aussi engagé de la
puissance publique dans son rôle de
facilitation de l'innovation l'élevés à
activer son nombreux utilisez la
commande de public pour favoriser
l'innovation simplifier les les
procédures administratives affiner les
dispositifs fiscaux existants faciliter
le financement privé de l'innovation
notre groupe
mes chers collègues sera à vos côtés et
sera engagé dans cette impératif j'ai la
sincère conviction que la France dispose
de tous les atouts nécessaires pour
relever ce challenge monsieur le
ministre replacer l'innovation
industrielle au cœur de l'économie
française est un défi qu'il est
impératif de relever dans les plus
belles délais je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Ghislaine panel vous avez 5 minutes
chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le Président mes chers collègues
dans un premier temps au nom du groupe
RDSE nous tenions à saluer le travail
réalisé par Monsieur le Président rédan
sarzy et Madame la rapporteur Paoli
gazelle pardon dans le cadre de la
mission d'information excellence de la
recherche innovation pénurie de champion
industriel chercher l'erreur française
lorsque le groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoire à impulser
l'initiative de réunir une mission
d'information sur cette thématique nous
avons été curieux et enthousiaste à
l'idée de débusquer des éléments de
réponse à ce qui pouvait s'apparenter à
un paradoxe à la française et force et
de constater qu'un parcourant le rapport
des faits historiques culturels
politiques économique et financier
viennent enrichir nos interrogations
initiales
nous comprenons très vite que notre pays
n'a pas traîné des pieds lorsqu'il a
fallu investir dans l'innovation et
ériger ce secteur en politique publique
à part entière
mais le revers de la médaille de ce
soutiennent à l'innovation par
l'accroissement des dépenses de
recherche et de développement des
entreprises montrent que cela
n'encourage pas à la spécialisation de
la production de la France dans des
branches d'activités particulières
phénomène qui amplifie notre fragilité
dans une économie de marché dérégulée
libéralisée privatisée et compétitive
l'une des réseaux évoquées pour
expliquer les difficultés liées à
l'organisation de grandes industries et
le recrutement de l'accès aux
compétences
or ce qui nous interpelle un peu plus
loin à juste titre dans ce rapport c'est
que je cite l'État a tendance à
considérer l'éducation et la recherche
comme des coûts ce qui conduit un
déficit structurel de leur financement
c'est une observation accablante mais
qui mais qui évoquait chaque année par
les acteurs de ce secteur non seulement
il aurait impossible de produire un
travail suffisamment qualitatif dans des
conditions dégradées mais également
parce que cela contrevient au respect
des droits fondamentaux comme l'égalité
d'accès aux droits à l'éducation
par conséquent il serait effectivement
bienvenu du juguler cette conception
mercantile de l'Enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche en se disant qu'il
s'agit d'un investissement sur l'avenir
pour former celles et ceux qui
incorporeront les exécutifs de
potentiels futurs industries
aussi un Européen convaincu nous
souscrivons totalement à la suggestion
relative à une meilleure coordination
des politiques d'innovation à l'échelle
nationale et européenne
la France doit être plus impliquée dans
la construction des orientations
stratégiques en matière de recherche et
d'innovation de façon que nous
laboratoires et voient au chapitre et
qu'ils puissent s'inscrire dans une
complémentarité plutôt qu'une
concurrence avec nos voisins européennes
cela revêt un enjeu d'efficacité et de
souveraineté pour limiter notre
dépendance aux grandes puissances ou un
minima la rendre bien moins asymétrique
en somme toutes les recommandations et
dictées dans le rapport revêtent une
grande importance mais certaines nous
paraissent particulièrement saiyanes
comme l'augmentation du nombre de sites
industriels qui en main pour une
meilleure planification de leurs
utilisations ce qui est source de
valorisation de filières s'appuyant sur
les savoir-faire locaux par ailleurs cet
outil pourrait avoir comme vertu de
recycler des sites industriels existants
dépourvus d'occupants depuis longtemps
en Arden néanmoins en tête la nécessité
d'une meilleure répartition de ces
investissements sur l'ensemble du
territoire national j'insiste bien sur
l'ensemble du territoire national en
tant qu’élu de la ruralité parce qu'il
s'agit d'un secteur qui représente un
gisement d'emploi et une source
d'attractivité non négligeable pour nos
régions en baisse démographique
l'adoption de critères économiques
écologiques sociaux et de souveraineté
pour évaluer l'objectif de promotion du
transfert technologique de l'innovation
et de l'innovation pardon et
fondamentale pour écrire définitivement
ce secteur dans les défis qui s'imposent
à la société tout entière et en fait la
volonté d'intégration au sein des
critères de la responsabilité sociale
des entreprises la collaboration des
grands groupes avaient start-up et les
PME innovantes est un premier pas
intéressant qu'il faut expérimenter mais
qui devra peut-être s'accompagner de
mesures plus coercitives car
permettez-moi de douter de la générosité
spontanée de certaines grandes sociétés
pour conclure voilà une partie de nos
observations et nous renouvelons tous
nous remerciements en direction de
celles et ceux qui ont impulsé ces
discussions capitales madame la
rapportiste la rapportrice pardon vous
trouverez du soutien de la part du
groupe RDSE pour faire avancer vos
recommandations je vous remercie merci
Madame Pantel la parole est à Monsieur
Serge babarie chers collègues vous avez
la parole pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le président de la mission de
la formation madame le reporter merci de
votre travail je suis le plaisir d'y
participer et chers collègues
je me réjouis que je sois évoqué à
plusieurs reprises tout au long de votre
rapport la situation et le rôle
singulier des PME et face à l'innovation
4 points en particulièrement retenu mon
attention premier point renforcer la
culture de l'innovation et de
l'entrepreneuriat
l'innovation d'entrepreneuriale devrait
effectivement être encouragée dès
l'école les formations à
l'entrepreneuriat généralisées dans
l'enseignement supérieur il faut mettre
fin à la culture de la peur de l'échec
de la honte pour encourager la
créativité et l'innovation
relancer l'esprit d'entreprise et
crucial dans un pays livré à la pente
dangereuse de l'assistanat
deuxième point faire converger le temps
administratif et le temps économique il
faut intégrer le temps de l'entreprise
dans les procédures administratives ça a
déjà été dit mettre en place des
procédures rapides pour agir et des lois
plurielles pour sécuriser
l'environnement juridique des
entreprises en matière de commande
publique former l'acheteur public à
l'achat innovant et le sensibiliser au
monde de l'entreprise est indispensable
ce sont des sujets qu'on a évoqués hier
soir déjà monsieur le ministre quant
allons-nous enfin copier les États-Unis
adopter un Small Business Act européen
les PME pourront enfin accéder à la
commande publique qui représente des
montants considérables
le triplement du plafond de l'achat
innovant irait également dans le bon
sens mais plus généralement ceux qui
ressort de votre rapport c'est la
nécessaire simplification des procédures
administratives les entreprises ont
besoin de pragmatisme de lisibilité de
simplicité en 2010 selon le CDE les
charges administratives représentaient
3% du PIB de la France
soit 60 milliards d'euros où en est-on
aujourd'hui
on est entre 75 et 87 milliards d'euros
selon une étude de l'iFRAP
en 2017 la délégation des entreprises
alors présidée par notre collègue
d'Elisabeth Lamure rendez un rapport
d'information relatif au moyen d'alléger
le fardeau administratif des entreprises
pour améliorer leur compétitivité pas
moins de 21 recommandations y étaient
formulées
une simplification ambitieuse des
démarches des entreprises favoriserait
la création et la croissance des
entreprises et par la même innovation
troisième point les aides fiscales et
financières on ne peut effectivement
penser innovation sans mettre en place
un environnement fiscal financier et
économique adapté je remercie d'avoir
souligné l'iniquité du versement du
crédit d'impôt recherche dans 77 %
revient au 10% des entreprises les plus
importantes les champs de côté la
plupart des PME
quatrième et dernier point le rôle des
acteurs privés
si la fiscalité le soutient public ont
évidemment leur rôle à jouer
l'investissement privé doit en être le
complément la posture de nos grandes
entreprises vis-à-vis de nos startups et
PME doit évoluer les grands groupes
n'aident pas nos petites entreprises
l'inscription de ce critère dans la RSE
serait une excellente chose pour que ces
grands groupes soient plus que des
grands frères bienveillants
monsieur le ministre je tiens enfin
insister sur le caractère
interministériel du sujet on ne peut
penser innovation et recherche sans
intégrer le développement économique
sans déboucher pour nous chercheurs pour
nos innovations le risque
malheureusement déjà constaté c'est la
fuite de nos cerveaux et le déclassement
de nos entreprises en raison de
l'obsolescence technologique n'oublions
pas que la conquête de nouveaux marchés
se fait sur les prestations de rupture
qui sont le résultat de l'innovation je
vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Madame Lord Arcos
vous avez la parole pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur ministre
monsieur le Président madame le
rapporteur la France était en train de
décrocher définitivement en matière de
recherche et d'innovation ma question
est évidemment provocatrice mais il faut
bien dresser le constat d'une situation
inquiétante pour notre pays qui
n'investit pas suffisamment dans sa
recherche depuis 25 ans en effet le
financement de la recherche publique de
la recherche privée stagne autour de
2,2% du produit intérieur brut à tel
point que nous avons abandonné à
d'autres pays européens le leadership en
matière de R&D
dans ces conditions nos gains
économiques sont nettement plus faibles
que ceux de nos voisins ayant fait de la
recherche et de l'innovation un enjeu
majeur de dynamisme industriel la loi de
programmation de la recherche pour les
années 2021 2030 que j'ai eu l'honneur
de rapporter était censé tenir la
promesse d'un réinvestissement massif
dans la recherche publique l'objectif
étant de parvenir à un effort national
de recherche équivalent à 3% du PIB elle
s'attachée également à renforcer
l'attractivité des métiers scientifiques
à consolider les dispositifs
d'évaluation d'organisation et de
financement de la recherche et à
faciliter la diffusion de la recherche
dans l'économie et la société
au moment d'examen de la LPR j'avais
affiché un optimisme très relatif tant
la trajectoire budgétaire me semblait
peu crédible et surtout peu efficace au
regard de l'importance de l'écart de
compétitivité à combler entre notre pays
et les pays européens les plus avancés
en matière de recherche et d'innovation
c'est d'ailleurs à l'initiative du Sénat
que l'intensité de l'effort budgétaire a
été renforcée sur les premières années
de la programmation j'avais en outre
émis des doutes sur la capacité de cette
loi à fixer un cadre réellement motivant
pour nos chercheurs et enseignants
chercheurs de nature à favoriser leurs
activités de recherche en France et non
à l'étranger l'absence de vision sur ce
qui doit être la politique publique de
recherche un moyen et long terme et sans
doute pour beaucoup
notre commission de la culture a
récemment rendu public son rapport sur
la mise en œuvre de LPR le bilan que
nous avons dressé démontre que ce texte
était nécessaire mais que son
application sur le terrain reste
perfectible
si elle constitue un bon début de
réinvestissement public dans la
recherche sa durée de 10 ans et
l'intensité de l'effort budgétaire sont
néanmoins reconsidérées d'autant plus
que cet effort est aujourd'hui très
largement absorbé par l'inflation notre
mission d'information sur l'excellence
de la recherche de l'innovation nous
nous rendons compte des travaux
aujourd'hui j'en profite pour saluer la
qualité de nos auditions et nos
déplacements et également remercier nos
administrateurs
juste pour sa part nécessaire de
considérer la recherche comme un
investissement de long terme dans
l'innovation trop longtemps hélas
l'investissement public dans la
recherche a été perçu comme un coup et
celle-ci a de ce fait régulièrement fait
fonction de variables d'ajustement pour
réduire le déficit budgétaire de l'État
or tout démontre à quel point cette
vision est néfaste pour la France la
recherche fondamentale nous en avons la
conviction se situe au cœur de
l'innovation et doit bénéficier d'un
puissant soutien financier sur le long
terme par ailleurs la politique de
rémunération des chercheurs doit être
plus attractive qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui si nous voulons retenir nos
meilleures chercheurs et attirer les
talents étrangers à fort potentiel le
cas d'Emmanuel charpentier jeune prix
Nobel de chimie parti mener ses
recherches pionnières et majeur hors de
France n'est pas un Canet de nautique
quand un chercheur de ce niveau fait le
choix de poursuivre ses recherches à
l'étranger il emporte avec lui son aura
ses financements ses compétences et ne
fera pas bénéficier de jeunes chercheurs
français de l'étendue de ses
connaissances je suis pour ma part
relativement optimiste pour l'avenir
même s'il ne faudra persister dans notre
effort budgétaire en effet le
réinvestissement dans la recherche est
en marche l'Agence nationale de la
recherche a connu une année 2021
exceptionnelle avec une augmentation
très significative des financements
alloués aux équipes de recherche et aux
établissements grâce à la LPR l'agence a
vu son rôle renforcé dans l'écosystème
de la recherche et de l'innovation et
ses missions ont été confortées les
budgets en croissance offre de nouvelles
perspectives d'accompagnement des
communautés scientifiques les premiers
résultats sont là le taux de succès aux
appels à projets génériques atteint
désormais plus de 23% et le taux de
préciput est passé de 19% en 2020 à 25%
en 2021 en outre le soutien à la
recherche partenariale a été
considérablement renforcée nous savons
qu'il s'agit d'un puissant levier en
faveur de l'innovation en conclusion de
cette intervention je voudrais souligner
trois enjeux majeurs auxquels nous
devrons apporter une réponse singulière
et courageuse il nous faudra tout
d'abord
opérer une clarification du paysage
français de la recherche celui-ci est en
effet caractérisé par une polarité
d'acteurs organismes nationaux de
recherche établissement d'enseignement
supérieur agence de financement unité
mixte de recherche aux missions pas
forcément bien réparties et aux
relations pas toujours fluides il nous
faudra ensuite donner un cap à la
recherche française la programmation
budgétaire de LPM n'a pas été
accompagnée d'un programmation
stratégique et cette incontestablement
une des raisons pour lesquelles la
communauté scientifique a modéralement a
modérément adhérer à la réforme promue
par le gouvernement il nous faudra enfin
encourager une meilleure articulation
entre recherche publique et secteur
privé et ce dès la mort des projets de
recherche car il n'y a pas d'innovation
sans recherche fondamentale si nous
sommes capables de répondre à ces trois
enjeux la France redeviendra un grand
pays innovant dans tous les secteurs
d'avenir système numérisé
nanotechnologie nouvelle énergie
biologie santé et nous pourrons ainsi
renouer avec notre brillant destin
collectif ce que nous appelons tous de
nos vœux je vous remercie de votre
attention merci
la parole est à Monsieur Claude malurey
monsieur m'aduré vous avez la parole
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président des
missions d'information madame le
rapporteur mes chers collègues le sujet
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui n'a rien de
nouveau et c'est là tout le drame voilà
plusieurs décennies que la France est
engagée sur la voie de la
désindustrialisation nous avons laissé
partir nos usines ne gardons ici que les
centres de décision c'était le rêve de
la mondialisation heureuse
le résultat est que nous n'avons plus
guerre d'usine nous exportons nos
cerveaux et nous importons les produits
que ces mêmes cerveaux formés sur
deniers publics fabriquent à l'étranger
nous sommes perdants sur toute la chaîne
de valeur
mais ce qui est heureux c'est que nous
en sommes désormais conscients il aura
fallu plusieurs crises et singulièrement
la crise sanitaire et la guerre en
Ukraine pour nous en rendre compte nous
avons perdu notre souveraineté
industrielle l'objectif est maintenant
consensus il faut réindustrialiser le
pays c'est bon pour nos importations bon
pour nos emplois bon pour la transition
énergétique bon pour la cohésion sociale
la bataille théorique a été gagnée nous
devons désormais passer à la pratique
or en la matière les choses se
compliquent d'abord parce qu'ils font
analyser précisément les causes de notre
déclin industriel ensuite parce qu'il
faut identifier les remèdes pour guérir
le mal et c'est souvent là que le bas
blesse c'est pourquoi je me réjouis que
le groupe des indépendants auquel
j'appartiens et lancer cette mission
d'information qui visait précisément à
identifier les principaux blocages qui
empêchent notre pays de convertir ces
innovations scientifiques en innovation
industrielle je tiens à saluer
l'engagement de Vanina paoligajin qui a
été à l'origine de cette initiative et
qui a mené un travail de fond pour
auditionner de très nombreux acteurs et
proposer des solutions opérationnelles
et concrètes à cet immense défi
ce travail a porté ses fruits toutes les
recommandations ont été adoptées à
l'unanimité c'est dire s'il y a
consensus sur le sujet
je ne reviendrai pas en détail sur
chacune d'elles le rapporteur a déjà
rappelé les principales mesures
notamment fiscales pour transformer les
sets de l'innovation je me contenterai
de tirer deux leçons du rapport la
première concerne la relation entre
science et entreprises
transformer les scènes l'innovation
c'est traduire les avancées
scientifiques en solution opérationnelle
c'est faire le lien entre la recherche
fondamentale et les projets
d'industriels entre le monde académique
et le monde de l'entreprise à cet égard
notre université recèle encore de très
puissants éléments de conservatisme il
n'est pas rare d'y croiser des
enseignants et des chercheurs qui
soutiennent mordicus que la recherche
pour rester pure ne doit surtout pas
trouver d'applications concrètes que
tout transfert de propriété
intellectuelles que tout brevet déposé
avec une entreprise est une
compromission terrible avec le grand
capital
ces réflexes corporatistes découragent
encore trop souvent l'évocation de ceux
qui veulent valoriser autrement leur
savoir et pour cause une incursion dans
un monde de l'entreprise est perçu par
les chercheurs comme un égarement de
carrière parfois
équipé peu pénaliser dans au sein de
l'université il faut donc repenser le
modèle académique pour permettre de
mieux appréhender ces trajectoires qui
sont enrichissantes à la fois pour nous
chercheurs et pour nous deux universités
j'espère que la récente attribution du
prix Nobel de physique à Alain Aspect
directeur de recherche et mérite du CNRS
à Paris Saclay professeur à
Polytechnique mais aussi grand
entrepreneur puisse les convaincre qu'on
puisse à la fois entreprendre et réussir
une carrière académique la deuxième
leçon que je tirerai du rapport
d'information c'est l'absolu nécessité
de simplifier notre bureaucratie nous
entrepreneurs mais aussi nos universités
nos chercheurs nos laboratoires tous
l'écosystème l'affirme sans embage la
France est un absurdistant ou le
formulaire et la norme et
l'administration l'arbitre de tout nous
avons laissé se développer tout d'un
ensemble de règles qui nous étouffent le
rapport prend un exemple Hélicon et le
camp pour démarrer l'activité d'un
laboratoire de thérapies géniques il
faut attendre près de 10 mois en France
en Suisse on part du principe que tout
est en règle et l'entreprise peut
commencer à produire cependant que le
dossier est instruit en bonne et due
forme
voilà ce que nous devons faire en France
miser sur la confiance et remettre
l'administration au service des usagers
ce n'est pas aux français et notamment
aux entrepreneurs qui prennent des
risques pour faire bouger les choses de
s'adapter à l'administration mais bien à
l'administration de s'adapter à eux il
est aberrant de financer par nos impôts
des délais qui font perdre de l'argent à
la collectivité pendant la crise
sanitaire le gouvernement a mis en place
des instrument très efficaces notamment
parce qu'ils étaient immédiatement
opérationnel bien sûr il y a eu des
erreurs et parfois des abus mais il y en
a-t-il plus lorsque la défiance prévoit
au sein de l'administration à mon avis
non évidemment j'espère que nous serons
capitalisés sur ces réussites récentes
pour stimuler l'innovation et
réindustrialiser le pays je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Roland Lescure ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie
madame la Présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
stimulant et motivant hier nous avons eu
un débat assez long ici sur la
souveraineté économique qui était un peu
plus déprimante au fond c'était les deux
faces de la même pièce nous regardons
tous vers l'avant et l'industrie
innovation vendent au Père pour le
développement de la France et je pense
qu'ici tout le monde y
depuis 5 ans notre politique se fonde
sur une triple accélération
accélération de la recherche et
développement il faut reconnaître j'y
reviendrai que ça remonte d'ailleurs
avant le quinquennat qui vient de
s'écouler l'accélération du transfert de
la recherche de l'industrie et
l'accélération de l'innovation
industrielle et ça je pense que c'est
nouveau madame la ministre Lindeman l'a
bien évoqué dans son intervention
les trois composantes de cette
accélération sont essentielles et sur le
gage d'une vraie culture de
réindustrialisation
le mythe funeste du fablesse
de la France sans usine que vous avez
dénoncé à raison notamment madame
massénatrice Sillinger nous en sommes
bel et bien revenu pourquoi parce qu'au
fond nous savons tous que l'industrie
salination un pays qui se
désindustrialise c'est un pays qui
devient moins évident un pays moins
innovant c'est un pays avec moins de
croissance et c'est ce tandem innovation
industrie qui permet en outre de prendre
le virage indispensable dans lequel nous
devons
aller accélérer parce qu'on y a déjà
quand même celui de la transition
écologique
c'est lui encore ce tandem innovation
industrie qui redynamise nos territoires
qui créent partout des emplois de tout
niveau de qualification c'est lui qui
nous permettra de rester une grande
nation sur tous les plans et partout
madame la satrice Pantel a bien insisté
sur la dimension territoriale de notre
politique elle est essentielle parce que
là où l'industrie recule l'extrémisme et
la colère progresse et si nous refaisons
avancer l'industrie dans les territoires
je suis convaincu que la colère et
l'extrémisme
bon sur l'innovation je pense qu'il faut
rendre à Nicolas casarkozy qui lui
appartient le réveil national sur
l'innovation il date de 2010 avec la
mise en place des programmes
investissement à venir à l'issue d'une
commission à l'époque déjà
transpartisane menée par deux anciens
Premiers ministres à la Juppé Michel
Rocard qui avait fait des
recommandations extrêmement innovantes
et qui à l'époque avait été mise en
œuvre
reconnaissons aussi que sur la partie
industrielle c'est plutôt ce
gouvernement qui a accéléré le grand
retour de la politique industrielle
française la définition de priorité
sectorielle pour l'innovation et le
soutien à l'émergence de la French tech
la french tech désormais
internationalement reconnu qui
représente je l'ai dit hier je le répète
aujourd'hui plus d'un million d'emplois
directs et indirects dans l'innovation
le président malurey la mentionné
l'innovation la technologie sont
essentielles
notre effort nos efforts pardon sur leur
financement des startups il paye après
avoir démontré leur résilience au cours
de la crise sanitaire les startups
tricolores ont déjà levé 8 milliards
d'euros sur les 6 premiers mois de
l'année 10 fois plus qu'en 2017 nous
avons 25 licornes en France soyez en
fier les champions ils sont en train
d'émerger et Madame Jourda oui vous avez
raison c'est aussi en Europe qu'ils
doivent émerger le président de la
République a lancé il y a maintenant
deux ans l'initiative Sky up Europe qui
vise à trouver des fonds européens pour
financer nos start-up européennes
d'ailleurs elles sont en partie
industrielle j'entendais madame la
ministre linman disant qu'on manque de
startups industrielles on en a quand
même 1500 aujourd'hui certes sur les
20000 startups que nous connaissons
c'est encore insuffisant et c'est il est
vrai beaucoup les services qui
aujourd'hui peuvent notre contingent de
start-up mais n'oublions pas évidemment
que l'industrie ça prend du temps il
faut 13 ans pour créer une véritable
entreprise de biotech à partir du moment
où elle démarre il faut 10 ans pour
créer une entreprise de technologie
profonde qu'on appelle la diptec
évidemment tout ça prend du temps et les
temps de développement des projets
industriels issus de la recherche et
développement ils sont longs nous
commençons en récolter les fruits et
nous allons dans le bon sens une
première génération de sites industriels
portés par les startups est en train
d'émerger le sénateur mondial a
mentionné nous avons une startup
aujourd'hui elle s'appelle Exotech elle
est dans le Nord elle est dans les
territoires elle est exceptionnelle j'ai
eu l'occasion de voir des robots qu'il
fabrique dans une autre une entreprise
exceptionnelle du Maine-et-Loire
l'entreprise Lacroix ces robots made in
France ils révolutionnent la logistique
et ils le font partout dans le monde
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
allons encore accélérer avec le
lancement du Plan start-up industriel
lancer en janvier dernier c'est un
objectif de 100 projets
d'industrialisation par an que nous nous
fixons et là encore ne souhaitons que
ces startups soient partout dans les
territoires nous déployons pour cela
plus de 2 milliards d'euros nous
renforcement notre accompagnement France
2030 va amplifier cette dynamique et le
président barari j'espère en sera
heureux 50% du plan de France 2030 sera
destiné à des PME innovantes votre
souhait de sanctuariser les financements
et de donner de la visibilité à tous les
acteurs madame le rapporteur nous le
partageons nous lui donnerons encore
avec France 2030 madame la sénatrice
d'Arcos nous reprochait de ne pas avoir
de cap sur la recherche notre cap pardon
c'est France 2030 je pense qu'il est
bien fixé et que c'est vers là que nous
devons aller
bon je vais terminer par notre point
désaccord le comité le fameux le fameux
crédit impôt recherche j'entends ce que
vous dites on peut sans doute faire
mieux et pour être franc on est prêt à
examiner en détail la manière dont on
pourrait optimiser davantage ce crédit
mais de grâce ne le touchons qu'avec la
main tremblante comme la Constitution il
est aujourd'hui extrêmement bien
identifié par les investisseurs
internationaux il permet aujourd'hui aux
ingénieurs français d'être compétitifs
par rapport aux ingénieurs
internationaux moi j'ai été député
jusqu'à il y a quelques semaines des
Français qui vivent en Amérique du Nord
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs français qui
réussissent en Amérique du Nord
aujourd'hui viennent installé leur abord
leur laboratoire par le recherche en
Europe en France et c'est grâce au
crédit impôt recherche que nous le
devons donc soyons prudents vous allez
par exemple mentionné l'abaissement du
seuil à 100 millions d'euros qui
rapporterait vous l'avez dit 700 euros
mais qui diminuerait les dépenses
au-delà de ses seuils d'un virgule 8
milliards d'euros nous avons besoin
vraiment de regarder en détail l'impact
des propositions que vous faites avant
de les mettre dans la loi parce que je
le répète ça fait partie de l'image de
marque de la France aujourd'hui dans le
monde entier et vraiment ne touchons-le
qu'avec la main tremble et je le répète
nous sommes prêts à entendre vos
propositions à les étudier dans le
détail et
avec nos équipes évidemment prêt à vous
accompagner sur ce chantier l'autre
grand chantier avant de je termine je
m'aperçois que je suis bien trop long
c'est celui de la commande publique vous
l'avez mentionné un certain nombre
d'entre vous la commande publique doit
être un vrai levier d'innovation un vrai
levier d'industrialisation un vrai
levier d'achat français j'avais eu
l'occasion de le dire déjà hier sur la
souveraineté finalement tout se recoupe
nous avons voté vous et nous à
l'Assemblée j'y étais à l'époque des
dispositions dans la loi ASAP dans la
loi pacte dans la loi qui m'a résilience
qui permette de le faire
sécurisé nos acheteurs notamment dans
les collectivités territoriales de
manière à ce qu'ils comprennent qu'on
peut acheter durable on peut acheter un
circuit court on peut acheter en
innovation on peut acheter français sans
tomber sous les fourches du code du
marché public
pour terminer je voudrais être
extrêmement clair la protection oui le
protectionnisme non notre industrie doit
être forte sur ses bases mais aussi
capable de conquérir le marché nous
devons attirer des capitaux en France ou
de vous construire des entreprises qui
seront capables de s'exporter qui sont
capables de conquérir le monde je suis
intimement persuadé que nous sommes
capables de le faire votre rapport
vanosier aider je ne serai pas plus long
si ce n'est vous dire que ce n'est pas
seulement le ministre de l'Industrie qui
vous parle aujourd'hui il a eu une
longue conversation avec la ministre de
l'éducation supérieure de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche madame
Retailleau
ancienne président de l'université de
Paris Saclay dans tes tissu notre prix
Nobel de physique nous sommes
parfaitement alignés à la fois sur notre
volonté d'avoir une recherche innovation
de classement mondiale très connectée
avec l'entreprise nous y travaillerons
de concerts nos équipes aussi je vous le
garantis merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
pour conclure le débat la parole est à
Monsieur Christian Redon sarrazzi
président de la mission d'information
monsieur le ministre madame le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs au moment de conclure ces
débats je souhaite insister sur le fait
que cette mission d'information qui
s'est passé s'est penchée sur un sujet
qui nous préoccupe tous quel que soit
notre nature politique et notre couleur
politique à savoir donc comment et à
quelles conditions l'innovation
peut-être nous permettre de reconquérir
notre souveraineté industrielle et
comment peut-elle nous permettre de
créer et de maintenir des emplois
pérennes dans nos territoires
cet après-midi le crédit impôt recherche
a été au cœur des débats mais faut-il
maintenir
une rampe de situation que nous avons
dénoncé et qui fait l'objet de critiques
régulières dans de nombreuses études
économiques je rappelle que les
modifications que nous proposons ne font
que corriger à la marge certains abus
sans porter atteinte au cœur du
dispositif le crédit impôt recherche
français restera le dispositif fiscal le
plus généreux parmi l'ensemble des pays
de l'OCDE pour favoriser la recherche et
le développement au contraire il sera
même plus généreux puisque l'actuel taux
de 30% sera augmenté à du concurrence
ces économies réalisées en supprimant le
taux de 5% au-delà des 100 millions de
dépenses de R&D et en calculant le
plafond du crédit pour recherche au
niveau de la holding de tête pour les
groupes qui pratiquent l'intégration
fiscale en outre il sera plus efficace
puisqu'il est bénéficiera davantage au
PME et aux ETI c'est-à-dire aux
entreprises pour lesquelles le levier du
crédit impôt recherche pour favoriser
les dépenses de recherche et de
développement et le plus important
quant à l'argument de stabilité fiscale
qui a été évoquée je pense qu'il ne
tient pas davantage
non seulement
comme le rapporteur la souligner comme
certains collègues ont rappelé le
contexte fiscal des entreprises a changé
mais en outre ce dispositif du Seigneur
n'a pas évolué depuis 14 ans le temps
d'une évolution est donc venu
d'autant que les études économétriques
démontent qu'une révision même marginale
du crédit pour recherche s'impose pour
garantir l'efficacité de la dépense
publique chers collègues à l'heure où le
Parlement est souvent critiqué pour son
impuissance j'espère que nous vous avons
convaincu de consigner de voter les
amendements transpartisans que Vanina
paoligaja et moi-même vous proposeront
au moment de l'examen du projet de loi
de finance afin de renforcer la
compétitivité de nos PME et ETI par
l'innovation au-delà du crédit impôt
recherche je souhaite insister sur une
autre mesure qui nous paraît importante
pour promouvoir l'innovation dans les
PME qui ne font pas encore appel au
dispositif d'aide à la R&D à l'instar de
ce qui se fait en Belgique nous
proposons d'instituer un coupon
recherche innovation de 30.000 euros
à destination des PME dans la limite
d'une enveloppe globale de 120 millions
d'euros ce dispositif permettrait
d'élargir le vivier des bénéficiaires
des aides à l'innovation à des PME
que la bureaucratie
associée au dispositif de soutien
l'innovation rebute parfois en effet nos
circonscriptions nous avons tous entendu
des chefs d'entreprise se plaintes
qu'ils n'ont ni le temps ni les
ressources humaines pour remplir les
dossiers d'appels à projet au cours de
nos auditions nous avons constaté que
c'était souvent les mêmes entreprises
qui bénéficiaient d'une année sur
l'autre des aides publiques notamment
parce qu'elles pouvaient s'appuyer sur
des services juridiques et une expertise
donc pour remplir ce type de dossier
nous avons également été choqués
d'entendre que 15% du montant des appels
à projets servirait en réalité à
financer des cabinets de conseils
chargés de monter les dossiers se coupon
recherche innovation vise donc à
rétablir une certaine égalité devant les
aides publiques en permettant au PME de
se lancer dans un processus d'innovation
indispensable pour leur compétitivité
future et donc pour leur pérennité mais
en veillant toutefois à un dispositif
qui ne sera pas trop complexe afin de
simplifier sa mise en oeuvre au-delà du
Parlement le gouvernement a également
son rôle à jouer pour soutenir la
réindustrialisation de notre pays par
l'innovation d'abord il doit mobiliser
la commande publique au service des
entreprises industrielles innovantes les
chefs d'entreprise
attendent moins de subventions que les
opportunités pour faire croître leur
chiffre d'affaires or la commande
publique représente chaque année 111
milliards d'euros à cet égard je
souhaite attirer votre attention sur une
autre idée fausse mais malheureusement
très répandue selon laquelle les règles
communautaires seraient à l'origine de
notre incapacité à utiliser la commande
publique pour soutenir nos entreprises
en réalité nous nous mettons nous-mêmes
des bâtons dans les roues à travers une
conception rigide et peureuse des règles
des marchés publics
enfin le gouvernement doit renforcer
toutes les initiatives de facilitation
des démarches administratives et de
raccourcissement des délais afin
d'aligner un temps administratif sur un
temps économique en conclusion si les
défis sont grands je suis comme madame
le rapporteur optimiste la France
dispose des atouts nécessaires pour
faire partie des grandes nations
innovantes le débat aujourd'hui a montré
une réelle prise de conscience aussi
bien de la part du président du
Parlement que du gouvernement désormais
il nous faut agir collectivement pour
améliorer l'efficacité des dépenses
publiques consacrées à l'innovation et
surtout de les mettre au service de la
réindustrialisation de nos territoires
de tous nos territoires et si vous me
permettez quelques secondes madame la
Présidente je profiterai de ma présence
à la tribune pour remercier donc
l'équipe des administrateurs sous la
houlette de Sandrine van campenheen donc
qui nous a accompagné tout au long de
ses nombreuses et longues auditions et
bien sûr remercier aussi vanilla
paoligaja à l'initiative avec son groupe
de cette de ce débat et dont l'expertise
n'a d'égale que l'engagement sur le
sujet on a pu le mesurer tout au long
des auditions et je ne doute pas que
dans quel continuera à mener le combat
et nous continuerons à mener le combat
qui a été le nôtre durant ces 6 mois
même 9 mois de travail merci beaucoup
merci monsieur le président
je vais suspendre la séance pour
quelques instants afin de permettre à
chacun de s'installer pour le prochain
point à l'ordre du jour la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]